[Music]
one potential treatment for kovat 19 is
among the most promising it's an
experimental procedure that transfers
blood plasma from a corona virus
survivor into the bloodstream of a
patient still battling the disease of
course moving blood from donors to
patients is the foundation of the blood
bank system that saves lives on a daily
basis in this country and its creation
is most credited to one man inspired to
act after the devastating pandemic that
struck in his own time
the American Red Cross is on the front
line in the fight against kovat 19 using
plasma as a lifeline says executive
medical director doctor of that Miller
even in the first pandemic in 1918 the
physicians and the medical people
understood that if you take less than
somebody who has recovered there has to
be something in their blood that we can
give to somebody else to help their
recovers the key to extending the life
of that blood was discovered by one of
dr. Miller's heroes the very first
medical director of the Red Cross what
led my father to go into medicine was
the fact that his sister Elsie died in
the 1918 flu and that law says Charlene
drew Jarvis is what motivated the
research of dr. Charles drew the man who
became the father of the nation's blood
banking system what he did was to
discover how to store and preserve both
whole red blood and plasma that the
plasma could be dried and then it could
be reconstituted in other words
separating that liquid yellow plasma
from blood oxygen carrying red cells
greatly improved the shelf life of both
from one week to nearly two months
making person-to-person transfusions
almost obsolete that was critically
important because we were in the middle
of the war and because we had soldiers
who were dying abroad they needed to
have whole red blood which of course
could not be provided on the battlefield
plasma was what was used
that war provided the demand when world
war ii started in 1939 there was a
request from brittany could we assist in
providing plasma the American Red Cross
then called on the expert dr. drew to
initiate the blood for Britain campaign
becoming its first medical director of
Blood Services thousands of British
lives were saved because of drew in his
revolutionary method but in 1942 drew
left his post disputing another form of
blood division the Army and navies
decision to segregate blood banks by
race he actually resigned in protest
because he said there's no scientific
basis on on which to segregate blood
only separate blood according to blood
type
Ernie Jarvis dr. Drew's grandson is
proud he stood by his principles
returning to Howard University to teach
and serve I think if you would ask dr.
drew what his greatest contribution was
it was to teach a generation of African
American physicians and surgeons one of
them was my father
dr. Ross Miller this is a tribute to dr.
Charles drew and there was a picture
right here you see the gentleman to his
right behind his right shoulder
that man is my father oh my goodness
well you know my father had confidence
in your father's ability to change the
world dr. Drew died in a car accident
when Jarvis was 8 years old
but this daughter a brain scientist
herself says his commitment to being the
best lives on he held us all to a very
high standard of excellence what we
understood from him is that we could
achieve we should achieve and we would
achieve his impact on modern medicine is
is almost immeasurable its monumental
and that process of separating red blood
cells from plasma is what we are still
using right now in this moment to
support patients who are trying to
recover
he hated and motivated two generations
worth of black physicians in this
country so many people now say you know
we need more of his kind of go get it
and excellence in the process of
motivating everyone in the field of
medicine because we have so much hitting
us Michele what a great story thank you
for sharing dr. Drew story I had never
heard it before and I love your familial
connection as well that always makes it
even more special for all of us